- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is rediscover yourself.
Over to you A.R. Rahman.
(rooster calling)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- What is modern is ...
Rediscovering yourself,
rediscovering the way
music is done is modern.
I do love to embrace
new technology and ...
new ideas.
Especially like in the film like "Slumdog"
where Danny I said just "Am
I a someone?", you know,
in the tradition of music and everything.
So it was like two
cultures meeting in way.
Like some of the people
who are very close-minded.
They say "Oh what are they doing?
"It's just noise.
"Rap is noise and heavy metal is noise".
So when you go into that frame of just
try to like something for what it is
You know, go take a lens and disrupt it
and try and analyze it.
So with this philosophy, I think.
I kept moving on for like eight years,
rediscovering myself.
- So rediscovered myself every day.
Every single day,
even just through this YouTube channel,
I rediscover myself.
I started this channel.
One of the main reasons was
I wanted to learn myself.
I wanted a better environment for myself.
I wanted to surround myself with people
who've done more than I've done
and learn from them.
And every time I make a top ten video
an "Entspresso" video,
"BelieveLife" video,
any of the videos that I put out
three times a day.
I put them up because I've
learned something from them.
When somebody says a message
I take it and I try,
not to be like them.
The goal isn't to be like that person.
It's to be a better version of ourselves.
And when they give you that message,
think about how it's
going to impact your life,
how it's going to impact your business.
How can you apply it some way.
If you're just consuming content
and you don't apply it anywhere,
it's not a good use of time.
It's a great mental exercise I guess
but nothing else is going
to change in your life
until you take action.
What's really interesting is
a lot of the lessons are the same.
From the musicians we've covered
and athletes and entrepreneurs
and inventors and politicians.
A lot of the messages are the same.
A lot of the messages
for success are the same.
But hearing it consistently,
I find helps.
If you are not getting
the results that you want,
if you have these big goals and
you're nowhere close to them
and you don't see that
happening in the next,
you know few weeks, months, years.
If you're not making
the progress towards it.
If you feel you have
the untapped potential
and you don't know how to
go out and accomplish it,
it's likely 'cause you
have a poor mindset.
From your parents and
the people around you.
From your neighborhood,
from your environment.
You have a poor mindset that
holds you where you are.
And the way to break free of it
is to surround yourself with people
who have a better mindset,
a more empowering mindset,
a more impactful mindset.
And so I do it by hanging around these
successful entrepreneurs every single day.
I don't have the people,
physical people that I can go and talk to
who push me to be better.
I get it by watching these videos.
And so I challenge you to think.
If you're not getting your goals,
look at your environment
and see if you're doing the right things.
And yes a lot of these
messages will be the same,
consistently over and over again.
But hearing it from somebody else
in the words that they use, sometimes,
that's the trigger.
And hearing it consistently
helps break free
of the poor mindset to go off
and accomplish bigger things.
And sometimes it's just
an issue of timing.
You may have heard the message before
but for some reason today
you're ready to hear it
and to actually take some action on it.
If you want to do big things,
if you want to accomplish a big goal
then you have to be continually
rediscovering yourself.
And if you're not doing it
then you're going to stay where you are.
So I encourage you to pick up the mantle
and take some action.
So the question of the day today is,
"I'm curious, what do you
do on a consistent basis
"to rediscover yourself."
Leave it down in the comments below.
Super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Andre Martin.
Andre, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word".
It really really really
means a lot to me man
and I hope you're enjoying the reading.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of "Entspresso".
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
(tapping)
- Sure we all have to all
set goals for ourselves.
I mean our planned destination
is to be ...
busy ...
and to you know adjust to
whatever you're introduced to.
And what I mean by that is
okay as an entertainer I
started off as a singer.
You know I grew to be a
dancer and a performer.
After becoming a performer
then I became an actor.
After becoming an actor
I became an entrepreneur.
After becoming an entrepreneur
I became an entertainer
on a different level of
introducing other artists.
Then, you know after
that I became a mentor.
- Right.
- You know, so I think just
- to continue to evolve
in a way that is beneficial
for growth of myself and others.
My likeness to continue to be
remembered throughout history
and associated with something great.
- Wow.
For me you know,
there's a mantra that ...
I've lived by.
And it is that the journey
of the destination is
really what it's all about.
The pursuit ...
is more important than
the actual destination.
So as long as you are moving,
as long as you are working,
that is the destination.
- Wow.
- Yeah, the journey.
- But really it is simply that
the journey is the destination.
- [Woman] I agree.
As long as you're working you're good.
As a writer you start
trying different things
and you try different chords
or different structures of songs.
Different beats that you've never really
explored that path before.
You know ...
And I think having always
been a writer first,
I'm obsessed with the syncopation of
the way that words sound when
they're said a certain way
and once I've kind of done something once,
I always want to go to
a different direction
and never repeat myself.
So as a writer, I think
that I've always hoped
that my music would
constantly be changing.
Because you never want to
make the same album twice,
the same song twice.
And you know,
my greatest hope has been that as I grow
my fans will grow up with me
and as I change and my life changes,
my music will change as well.
- Extreme team Minaj says,
"I love you but I'm curious
"why did you change your wrapping style
"from the come up days to today?
"I love both."
- I don't think I changed my rap style.
I think you guys were
just starting to hear me
and you didn't hear all of me yet.
That's it.
I've always been into
being weird a little bit.
But I think what people really mean
is that they think that
I've changed my persona.
And life is about growth and change
and I don't want to remain the same
for my whole life.
I want to be able to change
and you know I respect the people who ...
loved you know, '07 Nicki and
definitely going to give you
some stuff on Pink Friday.
Like I'm not forgetting anybody.
But I just also have to be true to me.
And the truth is,
I started seeing different things.
I started going different places.
I started eating different things.
I can't ...
It would be fraudulent to rap the same way
and look the same way and act the same way
because I am not the same.